a la plaza de san pedro' vacía una vez
más
en un domingo de pascua normal habría
unos 100.000 fieles reunidos para
recibir la bendición del papa pero esta
vez sólo hay unos 200 y están dentro de
la basílica debido a las restricciones
por el coi y password el mensaje del
papa francisco se centró en como la
pandemia continúa empeorando otros
problemas en el mundo pero espíritu de
un internet le solicitó a la comunidad
internacional en espíritu de
responsabilidad global la entera
comunidad internacional a un empeño que
se comprometa a superar los retrasos en
la distribución de vacunas ya facilitar
su entrega especialmente en los países
más pobres
juani país y people
el pontífice mencionó algunas naciones y
líbano está enfrentando crisis política
económica y sanitaria para muchos
cristianos de ese país es difícil
mantener la alegría este año es
completamente diferente en todo sentido
nunca tuvimos una pascua en la que
pagamos 35 dólares por una caja de
huevos
en sirias ni la guerra civil que ya
cumple una década ni la pandemia
frenaron a esta congregación de celebrar
la resurrección como símbolo de
esperanza
[Música]
que esta pandemia desaparezca que la
crisis en nuestra amada siria
desaparezca
entre tanto la pascua en rangún ha
tomado un nuevo significado el
movimiento de resistencia contra la
junta militar ha adoptado los huevos de
pascua como símbolo de protesta en su
discurso el papa expresó su apoyo a los
jóvenes que protestan en mianmar